has gum Razvan is pitiful so if you
don't know I brought a bug it's called
this book loves you you can pre-order it
right now link is in the description
it's gonna be amazing we're still
working on designing all the pages
though even though I finished
technically riding it and yesterday we
had a photo shoot and it was a lot of
fun I got to do a lot of weird [ __ ] my
dogs licked my face I was a soldier at
one point but if you pointed like if
you're gonna shoot that elbow my baby
yeah I almost made out with a steak
which was not weird that was a felt very
natural we also did some shot outside
and we found some of you bros since the
book technically is not finished yet I
want of course you rose to be part of
the book I think that would be amazing
high posts from the future here fits in
the past didn't really do a great job at
explaining what you need to do so pills
from the future is here to save the day
don't worry basically what I want you to
do is to print the picture this one
there's a download link for it in the
description now I want to see this
picture everywhere no matter if it's
weird crazy or inappropriate as long as
it's not illegal basically take it hold
it up or put it somewhere and then take
a picture of it then basically send it
to me and I need you to do it before the
20 seconds of July how to send it to me
all that information is in the
description you basically either post it
on Twitter or Instagram to add pewdiepie
hashtag Duck is coming I'm gonna pick a
couple of my favorite ones and they will
be part of this life-changing piece of
history book wallet opportunity I think
it'll be a lot of fun it's it's summer
what else are you gonna do with your
time let's be honest here can't believe
I'm telling my fans to go outside I'm
actually a bit disappointed in myself
but other than that I'm so excited for
this I'm so excited for the book it's
coming together so nicely and to have
you bros part of it just feels like that
has to be a thing so go out there and
make some art history whatever
all right breast that's all for me
thanks so much for watching and as
always stay awesome bros
you